وانا اعود الى الانجازات العربيه من
الرياضه الى الفن والانجاز هو تقرير لمجله
امريكيه نشرت قائمه لاعظم 200 مطرب ومطربه
في العالم ومن بين الاصوات كانت تواجد
لصوت عربي وحيد وهو المطرب المصريه ام
كلثوم التي اضربت وما زالت تضرب كل العرب
والاجيال لكن ليفت في التقرير هو مقدمه
التقرير اللي شرحوا فيها النقاد انها ليست
لاعظم 200 صوت وانما الاعظم 200 مطرب لانه
الكثير من الناس ولده باصوات ونغمه مثاليه
ولكن الذي هم اكثر هو الاصاله والتاثير
واتساع
تراث الفنان الثقافي كوكب الشرق اللي وصلت
للعالميه واحتلت المركز الواحد والستين
ضمن القائمه وما كانت فقط العربيه الوحيده
في القائمه بل تفوق على مايكل جاكسون
وبالعالم سوريا
مايكل وفي تعريف المجله بتقريرها عن ام
كلثوم كتبت انه كوكب الشرق ليس لها مثيل
حقيقي بين المطربين في الغرب وتجاوز
تاثيرها العالم العربي وكان واضح هذا
التاثير عندما اعتبرها الديلان عظيمه
واستخدم الديونسي كلمات اغنيه انت عمري في
تصميم رقصتها عام 2016 طبعا هذا بالاضافه
للكثير من الفنانين الغربيين اللي اجمعوا
على عظمه كوكب الشرق التي كانت وما زالت
مناره والطريق الوحيد للوصول لقلوب
المحبين فليس هناك اجمل من العيش في القلب
ام كلثوم
ختام الحلقه تفاعلكم اليوم الى اللقاء
تاركني الايام
[موسيقى]
امرت
نا
ومر
[موسيقى]
مرت الايام
وابي الخصمتك ونسيت الليل اللي سهرته وق
تخاص
[موسيقى]
م
ين ما اعرفش ازاي انا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]